[Musik]
kinder kinder
ich bin heuer politik vertretungslehrer
herr dorn kneter sitzt im knast weil er
die michael aus der 9b geschwängert hat
aber michael hat jetzt eine einzige bio
ende gut alles gut
thema heute der bildungsnotstand wer von
euch ja in letzter zeit auf der
schultoilette sind sie wahnsinnig
niemand geht auf dem schulklo da könnt
ihr den bildungsnotstand live und in
farbe erleben und was für farben himmel
grün in allen schattierungen leuchtendes
greenstein geld in einer kabine zieht
ein trotziges betroffen sind seine juni
groß unter dem waschbecken und etwas
großes sagen es kann aber auch der
vertrauenslehrer gewesen sein
hier diskutieren verschwunden siehste
und nicht nur das scheißhaus die ganze
schule fällt auseinander und warum war
kein geld da ist falsch es ist ohne ende
steuergeld da unser finanzminister hockt
auf einem gigantischen berg ole jetzt
fragen sich die politiker geben wir das
geld für doofe kinder aus also für euch
oder für was sinnvolles wie
bankenrettung oder
bundeswehr-hubschrauber die nicht
fliegen und für was entscheiden die sich
kleiner tipp die doofen kinder sind
nicht untersagt dass die sbb schuld drin
klar auch je länger die spd ein land
regiert desto schneller verfällt ist das
ist die so genannte hannelore kraft
formel spd plus zeitgleich kaputt im
quadrat früher in den 70ern da war noch
geld da da wurden moderne schulen gebaut
und die meisten schüler aus der zeit
sind tot
beide hütten asbest verseucht sind aber
egal ob über unsere schule ist doch so
alt ist doch asbest drin ist drin
ja aber das ist ungefährlich verglichen
mit dem formaldehyd in den tischen
sollten wir also cdu oder fdp wählen
damit in der bildung besser läuft noch
intelligenter fragen zum
bildungsnotstand maden schüler also ihr
sind nicht mehr unsere zukunft sondern
ein lästiger kostenfaktor
keiner mag euch das sieht man ja schon
man den beschissenen nahmen die euch
eure eltern gegeben haben
das war es mal wieder für heute aus
aufgabe bis morgen versorgt auf dem
schwarzmarkt ein paar stangen bücher mit
und renoviert das schulklo
[Musik]